lo que vamos a hacer en este vídeo es
utilizar la calculadora gráfica de
sismos y en especial la vamos a usar
para explorar la relación entre las
cintas verticales y las horizontales y
también cómo se relacionan con lo que ya
conocemos de límites bueno podemos
empezar por graficar 2 entre x menos 1
aunque lo vamos a poner por aquí
inmediatamente podemos observar que algo
muy interesante ocurre cuando x es igual
a 1 si nosotros en la fórmula de esta
función sustituimos x igual a 1 lo que
tenemos es 2 entre 0 y siempre que
tengamos alguna expresión distinta de 0
entre alguna otra expresión que es 0 en
algún punto esa es una señal de que
probablemente tenemos una cinta vertical
y de hecho también podemos graficar esa
a sin total en x igual a 1 pero bueno
también es muy interesante preguntarnos
se relaciona esto con los límites por
ejemplo qué pasaría si tomamos el límite
conforme x tiende a 1 de 2 entre x menos
1 y podemos pensar en eso como un límite
por la derecha y como un límite por la
izquierda entonces vamos a alejar la
imagen bueno tal vez no tanto y vamos a
colocar esto por acá y entonces podemos
ver conforme x se acerca a 0 que cuando
x es igual a 0 fx es menos 2 y luego
cuando x es igual a 0.5 fx es menos 4 y
la función se va volviendo cada vez más
negativa conforme x se acerca cada vez
más a uno por ejemplo si nos acercamos
todavía más la función se va volviendo
cada vez más negativa ok por ejemplo si
hacemos x igual a punto 91 la función es
menos 22.222 y
eso que todavía nos quedan nueve
centésimas para acercarnos al 1 el
límite conforme x tiende a 1 de esta
función no está acotado
algunas personas dirían que el límite se
va hacia menos infinito pero en realidad
es un límite indefinido aunque yo es un
límite que no está acotado no ha cortado
en la dirección negativa claro que lo
mismo sucede si nos aproximamos a uno
por la derecha ok si estamos por acá si
tomamos un x que se acerque cada vez más
a uno podríamos observar que el límite
por la derecha tampoco está acotado es
un límite que se va hacia el infinito
positivo aunque ya está no ha cortado
del lado positivo ok
este límite no existe este es un ejemplo
clásico de una sin tota vertical y ahora
vamos a compararla con un asiento está
horizontal las cuales de hecho si pueden
tener un límite
es que vamos a empezar borrando estas y
vamos a ver la gráfica de esta función
la cual se ve bastante padre cierto nos
pusimos a diseñarla justo antes de que
empezáramos a grabar este vídeo pero
bueno además de observar que se ve
bastante divertida podemos ponernos a
pensar en cómo se comporta conforme x
tiende a infinito ok si nos enfocamos en
qué pasa conforme x tiende a infinito
por ejemplo podemos fijarnos por acá
conforme x aumenta y aumenta y aumenta
si le llamamos a toda esta expresión a
la función evaluada en el x
correspondiente conforme x aumenta
parece como que la ye se va aproximando
cada vez más a tres cierto por lo que
podríamos decir que tenemos una cinta
horizontal ye igual a tres y de hecho
también lo podemos decir con más
formalidad podemos decir que el límite
conforme x tiende a infinito
esta función es igual a 3 por aquí
cuando evaluamos la función en estos
valores de x la función nos da un valor
muy parecido a 3 y por supuesto también
podemos pensar en qué pasa cuando x
tiende a menos infinito y por aquí nos
estamos acercando cada vez más a 3 por
abajo
aquí tenemos 2.88 y 2.909 ahora una cosa
muy interesante acerca de la sas into
estás horizontales es que por ejemplo la
misma función puede atravesar a la a sin
tota por ejemplo aquí la función está
atravesando la a sin tota en esta área
que tenemos en medio y otra cosa muy
interesante que puede pasar con lajas
into estás horizontales es que la
función puede oscilar alrededor del
valor de la a sin total porque hay por
ejemplo podemos hacer oscilar a esta
función poniendo por aquí
una multiplicación por el seno de x y
listo ya lo tenemos aquí
esta función está oscilando alrededor
del valor de la acin total que lo
podemos ver de cerca y lo podemos ver
conforme x se hace más grande la función
sigue oscilando alrededor del valor de
la a sin tota pero de todas formas el
límite cuando x tiende a infinito de
toda esta función existe incluso aunque
la función cruce y cruce el valor de la
a sin tota la función se acerca cada vez
más a la a sin total conforme x se
vuelve más grande y bueno esta es una de
las principales diferencias entre las as
into estás horizontales y las verticales
si tenemos una a sin tota vertical la
función no puede cruzar esa a sin total
acaip justo porque tenemos una función
sin embargo si estamos hablando de una
sin tota horizontal la función
definitivamente puede cruzar muchas
veces la a sin toca y de todas formas el
límite existe
cada vez nos acercamos más a ese valor
ya sea si estamos tomando el límite
cuando x se va a infinito o cuando x se
va a menos infinito y listo ya
terminamos